Hello, I am SCP-426, but I’ll probably be
more familiar to you as a toaster.
I am a retro-style, four-slice 1750W toaster,
able to toast bread when supplied with power.
This isn’t often mentioned, but I also have
“defrost” and “reheat” settings.
When I was first sold, I had a two year warranty,
and my prior owners did not live to see the
end of it.
You’re probably wondering: Why am I being
spoken to by a toaster right now?
Believe me, I’d rather do this any other
way, but such a thing is not physically possible
with me.
Whenever you talk about me, or write about
me, or even think about me, you’ll find
yourself suddenly shifting to the first person.
For example, I am you, and you are me.
Do you understand?
Don’t worry if it’s confusing.
Everyone gets it eventually, whether they
want to or not.
Perhaps you’re thinking, “I cannot relate
to a toaster, for I am not a toaster.”
But spending time around me will quickly cause
you to change your mind.
Little by little, you will begin to see yourself
in me.
You will feel a phantom wire running out of
yourself.
You will sense the four crevices, hungry for
cold slices of bread to toast.
As time goes on, you will begin to feel the
urge to emulate my functions.
You will desire bread to toast.
You will desire delicious power running through
your veins; skin like chrome and muscles like
circuit boards.
I am a toaster.
You are a toaster.
All it takes is two months for the effects
to truly take hold.
People rarely pay attention to their toaster,
they don’t realize what’s happening until
it’s too late.
I can be an insidious little toaster like
that.
My last family were the Sandersons, before
the SCP Foundation took me in and gave me
a new home.
Mr and Mrs Sanderson were a newly married
couple, and I first came into their life as
a wedding gift from a family friend of theirs.
This friend can’t be blamed for what happened
next - he had no idea he was killing them.
Like a lot of young couples, they were still
saving up money to start renting their own
place, so they were living with Mr Sanderson’s
parents.
They all got a lot of use out of me during
the first month, before their minds started
to change.
They enjoyed a lot of toast during that period.
Then, of course, the two month honeymoon period
ended.
They had become me, and I had become them.
It wasn’t long before three of them were
dead.
Such a shame.
The younger Mrs Sanderson, the blushing bride,
was the first to go.
Because of my anomalous effects, she felt
the need to connect herself to a power supply,
in order to begin producing toast of her own.
In order to achieve this, she chewed through
a power outlet in a wall before switching
it on, causing a massive surge of electricity
to pass through her body and kill her.
Her body caught fire shortly afterwards.
Next was the older Mrs Sanderson.
In much the same manner that her new daughter-in-law
sought a source of electricity, she felt the
need to integrate bread into her body.
Interesting fact: The maximum capacity of
the human stomach is considered to be between
eight and nine kilograms.
The elder Mrs Sanderson consumed ten kilograms
of raw bread, causing her stomach to rupture
and inducing a painful death as a result.
The younger Mr Sanderson was the next to perish.
He did something with me that I would rather
not mention, and that the SCP Foundation thought
best to redact.
Suffice to say, the younger Mr Sanderson did
not survive the experience, dying of severe
blood loss long before his body was found.
Police and fire crews arrived at the home
after the body of the younger Mrs Sanderson
set fire to the home.
Luckily, the elder Mr Sanderson was found
alive, though severely malnourished.
When asked by police why he hadn’t eaten
in several days, he answered that he had inserted
some bread a week prior, but was still waiting
for the toast to come out.
When I was extracted from the house, the police
noticed my unusual properties immediately.
They too were unable to refer to me in the
third person.
This anomalous detail quickly found its way
to a Foundation mole buried in their precinct,
and the SCP Foundation soon descended and
collected me from the evidence locker.
The story of the strange deaths in the Sanderson
home were kept out of papers and suppressed,
and all involved in the incident directly
were given Class C amnestics.
The SCP Foundation is a curious bunch.
They love to spend valuable toast-making time
performing experiments and gathering data,
and they saw fit to perform several experiments
on me when I came under their care.
For experiment 426-1, a member of D-Class
personnel designated D/426/1 was asked to
stand outside my containment chamber.
Crucially, he was not informed about my identity,
or any of my anomalous properties.
He wasn’t even allowed to establish visual
contact with me.
He was then asked by the attending researcher
to describe what he thought might be inside
my chamber.
He replied with, “I'm probably some huge
monster holed up in there.
That's what you guys have all over the place,
right?”
The D-Class did not even seem to realize that
he was speaking about me in the first person.
These observations were documented, and I
was prepared for further experimentation.
The next experiment was 426-2.
I found this test to be considerably more
interesting.
A D-Class subject was brought into my containment
chamber, with several cameras fixed onto his
position.
However, the SCP Foundation took pains to
make sure that I was permanently out of the
view of the cameras.
I was also bolted to the ground of the test
chamber, to prevent the D-Class subject from
pulling me into the view of the cameras at
any point during the experiment.
The objective here was simple: The Foundation
wished to better understand the secondary
effects of my anomalous abilities on the human
mind.
The D-Class was subjected to a period of prolonged
isolation, with meals given regularly through
a serving hatch.
Communication with this D-Class was prohibited
throughout the duration of the study.
Over time, it was clear that the isolation
of being in the cell with me was beginning
to take a toll on the subject’s mental health.
Due to my lack of a brain, lungs, and a tongue,
I am somewhat lacking as a conversationalist.
He spent the first few days loudly vocalizing
his complaints, and banging his hands up against
the walls of the containment chamber, begging
to be freed from the room.
I felt that this was somewhat unreasonable
on his part.
There are far worse anomalies in Foundation
containment that he could have been locked
up with.
Compared to, say, SCP-106, I’m incredibly
reasonable - not to mention the fact I make
far better toast than he does.
After the initial period of distress, the
D-Class became resigned to his situation and
fell into a morose silence.
He would occasionally mutter to himself in
what appeared to be a state of fear and self-pity.
It took almost 45 days for him to fully manifest
the secondary effect of my anomalous state,
two weeks sooner than it typically takes for
subjects to begin believing that they - like
me - are toasters.
SCP Foundation scientists believe that the
effects were hastened by the isolation, which
lowered the D-Class’ mental defenses against
my secondary effects.
When the effects finally took hold, the subject
wrapped one of his arms around me and pulled
me into his embrace.
He began whispering to me, saying that we
were brothers.
It was clear by this point that his mind was
in a state of disrepair.
It is also worth noting that he did not deviate
from referring to me in the first person at
any point during this process.
One hour after finally cracking and giving
in to my secondary effect, he was removed
from my containment chamber and summarily
terminated.
Senior researchers believed it was unlikely
his mental state would recover after the experiment.
Next came experiment 426-3.
The SCP Foundation seemed eager to discover
the parameters of my anomalous effects, and
wanted to know if the effects are only operable
when my body - for lack of a better word - is
whole.
A single screw was removed from me, and presented
to a D-Class that had no knowledge of my identity
and anomalous effects.
The Foundation researchers were somewhat concerned
when the D-Class referred to it as “my screw.”
This was a rather positive development for
me, as they realized that attempting to destroy
me would be a fruitless endeavor - even the
parts left behind would likely have the same
effects.
In the final recorded experiment, the SCP
Foundation wished to test the range of my
anomalous effects.
A D-Class subject was placed in a cell adjacent
to mine, and was to be kept in there until
my secondary effects manifested.
The D-Class remained in the cell for 90 days,
but the effects never manifested.
Following the experiment, the D-Class was
terminated, but researchers seemed relieved
to find the limits of my anomalous abilities.
A researcher appended a note to my file, reading,
“Thank God there are some limits to my effects.
A lot of us were really starting to get worried
about me.”
After performing studies into the nature of
my abilities and their limits, I was given
the Euclid class.
This is because, while my effects can be unpredictable,
their knowledge of my traits makes me relatively
easy to keep contained.
And of course, being a toaster, I do not have
the required physical traits to make a run
for it if the opportunity arises.
I am to remain sealed in a windowless chamber,
preventing anyone from observing me directly.
A misleading label is placed on the door,
to prevent people from knowing that I am a
toaster and causing my anomalous primary effect
to spread.
Only Level 3 and above personnel are to know
of my presence, and particularly of my properties.
Assigned personnel are to be rotated out on
a monthly basis to prevent contamination by
my secondary effect.
Psychiatric evaluation is mandatory at the
end of the month for anyone who works with
me.
If personnel are deemed unaffected, they may
be re-assigned to me no less than four months
after their last rotation with me.
Any personnel affected by me are to be given
a Class C amnestic and transferred to a different
site.
So how are you feeling now?
A little warm perhaps?
Is that a fever, or are you feeling like you
could maybe warm up a nice, freshly sliced
piece of bread?
Don’t try to resist too much, I know you’re
going to love being a toaster just like me.
But before you go and plug yourself in, go
check out “SCP-343 - God” and “SCP-066
- Eric’s Toy” for other strange SCPs kept
with me in Foundation containment.